When I was a kid, I used to read these books called Choose Your Own Adventure.
And the idea of Choose Your Own Adventure is that you are the protagonist and
you get to make choices about what to do at various points along the storyline.
And based on what you do, you get sent to another page.
You get to see what happens as the results of your choices.
And in that spirit, for this final lesson,
I'm going to have you choose your own algorithm to investigate.
We've given you your first three and hopefully a little bit of a structure for
how you can approach them.
Now we're going to guide you through doing it on your own.
And in the future, as you become a more advanced machine learner,
you'll be doing this on your own all the time, so this is your first chance to
leave the nest and to find about a new algorithm on your own.